what i want to do in this video is prove
that the circumcenter of a right
triangle is actually the midpoint of the
hypotenuse and to do that i'm going to
first take a look at the the
perpendicular bisector of one of the
legs of this of this right triangle so
let me construct the perpendicular
bisector of leg bc right over here so
it's going to look something like this
this it intersects at a right angle it's
perpendicular and it bisects it so b the
distance from b to this point which
we'll call m maybe m for midpoint is the
same as the distance from m
to c so those two distances are going to
be equal
and let's call the point where this
perpendicular bisector intersects the
hypotenuse let's call this o and we're
going to prove that o is the
circumcenter of this right triangle
now the first thing that you might
realize and this is what we've seen in
many problems the triangle obm looks
similar to triangle abc and it's
actually not too hard to prove they both
already have a 90 degree angle so if we
show that they they both have another
angle another set of corresponding
angles that are congruent to each other
then we know that they're similar by aa
similarity and they both clearly share
this angle right over here obc is part
of the smaller triangle and abc which is
really the same angle is part of the
larger triangle and so and they also
obviously share a 90 degree angle so by
a a triangle similarity we have triangle
obm
is similar is similar to triangle a b c
is similar to triangle
a
b c
and what's useful about this is we know
that similar triangles the ratios
between corresponding sides are a
constant so for example we know that the
ratio between side bm which is on the
smaller triangle we know that the ratio
between bm let me do this in a different
color just to just for the sake of it we
know that the ratio between bm
and bc
bm and bc the ratio of this side on the
smaller triangle to the corresponding
side on the larger triangle is going to
be the same as the ratio of the
hypotenuse on the smaller triangle
bo to the hypotenuse of the larger
triangle because they are similar well
we know what the ratio of bm to bc is bm
is half of bc so this ratio over here
the ratio of bm to bc is going to be
equal to one half this is m is the byte
is the midpoint of these things so this
is exactly the same distance as this so
this is one half of the entire bc
so if one half is equal to bm over bc is
equal to bo over ba
we then know if we just kind of ignore
this middle part right over here that
one half is equal to bo
over ba
and if you cross multiply it if you
cross multiply you see that well there's
multiple ways to think about it but you
could just cross multiply and you'd say
ba
is equal to 2
bo or if you divide both sides by 2 and
they're really equivalent statements one
half
b a is equal to bo so bo is one half of
ba so this is one half
ba and so this other length ao right
over here this is going to be b this is
going to be this is going to be ba minus
one half ba so this is also going to be
one half
ba and so this segment right over here
ao ao is going to be congruent to ob
so what we've just shown first of all is
that this perpendicular bisector right
over here the perpendicular bisector of
segment bc it intersects the hypotenuse
of our right triangle at the midpoint so
we've already established so we one
thing that we've already established is
o
is the midpoint
of the hypotenuse of the hypotenuse
of the hypotenuse a b well that by
itself is interesting
but we also know that if a point sits on
a perpendicular bisector of a segment
it's equal distant it's equidistant from
the endpoints of the segment we showed
that in a previous video so we also know
that o
o b
it's equidistant from the endpoints of
this segment right over here that ob
is equal to oc but we know from this
first statement right over here that ob
is also equal to oa
ob is also equal to o a and so if ob is
equal to oc ob is equal to oa that means
oc must be equal to oa
c
must be equal to o a or another way to
think about it is that this point o
is equidistant from all of the points on
our trial all of the vertices i should
say this point o is equidistant from all
of the vertices of our triangle of our
triangle so this distance
this distance which is really going to
become our circum radius is the same as
this distance right over here which is
the same as this distance right over
there so that we know that o
is equidistant
equidistant to
all
all vertices
which is another way of saying that o is
the circumcenter o is
the circum
center so we've just proven that if you
have the circumcenter of a right
triangle it is the midpoint of the
hypotenuse of the right triangle or the
other way around that the hypotenuse of
the right triangle is the circumcenter
because you only have one circumcenter
of any of any triangle